dancing of course is a huge part of
Cuban culture so I decided to take a
lesson so now we will start with some
couple dance do you know how to dance
do I know how to dance now you pull the
string you pull so we will sound under
the first dance position first dance
position the hand is right on her back
right on her back right here yes haribol
haribol stop here okay this is the back
from here - yes and down here no no no
no no sounded up here this is the
there's a line here and I don't slow
down I yes right yeah look at this is
one two three on five six seven and one
two three on five six seven on one two
three on five six seven it's pretty easy
very easy alright so now I have one
concern about Lema I am worried that she
my partner will fall in love with me
okay now take the second basic you are
ready clever boy second base second base
E Oh second please
one two three on five six seven and back
two three and now forward the first one
and one two three five six
[Applause]
having some I was worried about my
partner
yeah so I looked down that's why I see
if she was okay yeah and she's okay can
I borrow her for a while
do you really know how to dance
cause you are so good dancing thank you
so I have an exercise for you is the
next one okay okay here we go one two
three five six seven one two three five
six seven one two three five six seven
and one two three five six seven
what's going you move my body but you
have my permission to touch my body
anywhere all right okay okay
no time you get up and
Isaacson is the main tres Cinco say una
mirada a fondo tres Cinco ma
I don't know why I will think I was
drawn to him let me show you let me show
you this movement and to probably karate
so you will have the first into play
yeah you will stay behind her Yeah right
stay behind and then from macho we can
do that one
I see laughing okay good on so anything
else yes one quick question I have heard
about the legendary rumba rumba rumba
rumba rumba all right
rumba and I here to say very sexually
charged dance yeah I must learn this
dance I must learn the Rumba so
basically we will have this song bases
like one and two and three you know so
she's so he's with the pelvis it can be
with the arms it could be here and she's
covering she's covering up she's saying
no no no yeah we goes two and three
[Laughter]
[Applause]
end of the world
[Music]
[Applause]
you